head of news and current affairs at
channel 4 house call Boris Johnson and
known liar who is copying Putin's
approached the media and says it's the
responsibility of broadcasters to
challenge politicians when they're not
being truthful
Dorothy Bern made the comments during
the McTaggart lecture at the Edinburgh
Television Festival what do we do when a
known liar becomes our prime minister
I've talked to journalists from several
news organizations about this issue they
said they would be loath to use that
word liar is it time for us to start
using the l word I believe that we need
to start calling politicians out as
Liars when they lie if we continue to be
so polite how will our viewers know that
politicians are lying
Arthur Bern joins us now from Edinburgh
hello it's you Dorothy it's always good
to see thanks for joining us on the
program this afternoon what did you hope
to achieve with that attack on Boris
Johnson last night I think we do need to
think as journalists particularly
television and radio journalists what
we're going to do if politicians don't
tell the truth because we're British
were very polite about it and we use
words like strange or say Oh perhaps
that is not quite the case but in these
times I think we need to be clearer with
our viewers when politicians are not
telling the truth because as I said
otherwise how will the viewers know that
the truth is not being told but I also
think that we need to give a lot more
detail to our viewers about policies
that we are examining traditionally I
think we've all put detailed
fact-checking on our websites and I
think that we need to actually put more
of those fact-checking details into our
broadcast reports to help our viewers
for themselves one of the points I made
was it's impossible for viewers
themselves to tell whether something is
true or not we actually did a survey of
1,700 people we gave them six stories
three were true and three were false and
only 4% of people could tell which was
which that shocked me but then I
realized well why should they know
because they've all got jobs to do homes
to run and they rely on us to do the
fact-checking for them was there
anything specifically that you were
thinking about when you'd written that
speech I mean we know that Boris Johnson
has lied he was sacked for lying for
with his column that he wrote in a
national newspaper previously it's an
actual fact that he has lied but I
wonder why you typically brought it up
for what purpose were you hoping to
achieve that I think one of the things
that concerns us all as journalists and
voters is that we look across the
Atlantic Ocean at the United States
where it has become accepted that Donald
Trump's lies as a matter of course the
Washington Post actually counted ten
thousand lies and some of his lies are
simply stupid for example he said that
his father was born in Germany he said
that the sound of windmills gives you
cancer so my concern is that we should
not become like the United States where
truth is no longer regarded as something
of primary importance we must both as
journalists and as voters say that a
belief in the central importance of
truth is vital for democracy yeah I mean
we've become a massively divided nation
haven't me Dorothy and that's not least
because of what's happened with brexit
and the fact that Boris Johnson
flip-flopped on that before he decided
which side he wanted to take you
certainly acknowledged that in your
speech but but
no inflammatory language like lier
suggesting that our Prime Minister is a
liar
does that not divide our country still
further I think it's not that l-word
isn't a word that I would bandy about
but I think when we are divided the one
thing that we must unite on is the
central importance of truth you know in
the u.s. it has started to be that a
number of political figures have said
that each person's truth is just a
matter of their own opinion there is no
such thing as truth and if you think
something's true then it's true and what
I'm saying is we mustn't go down that
road and so this is I suppose in many
ways a warning to politicians that
you've got to tell the truth and if you
don't we will call you out so keep your
own house in order it's not about me
being against any individual politician
I have huge respect for politicians I
think it's remarkable that people go
into public life and undergo such
unpleasantness as happens in political
life now so I'm not against politicians
I'm for truth we have to be our side of
the bargain
is that we have to be independent
broadcasters you know that's what we
have to be if we want our politicians to
uphold their end of the bargain you know
and I have to put this to you one of you
your execs liked an abusive tweet about
Boris Johnson on Twitter and one of your
presenters has not been particularly
impartial about the Tories I'm guessing
that's what they would come back at you
with if they were here standing where I
am today
well I think your point about the Tories
is an allegation that has never that
someone person made on Twitter that was
never proved
nobody should like a rude remark about
anybody and we must be absolutely Julie
impartial if anybody who works for me is
not truly impartial I can tell you they
get into trouble and also we have
regulators to whom people make
complaints and you'll know cave they
really do make complaints and they will
hold us to account if were not really
impartial I completely agree with you
that we have to be fair and equal about
talking about British politics lots to
talk to you about I hope you've got a
few more minutes to spend with us I know
you've been in the business we've been
in in the business a long time our paths
of necessarily cross but we started to
Granada around about the same time you
said this yes about Boris yesterday I
just want to play it to our viewers and
then I want to ask you about it Boris
Johnson and this is what and Dorothy
said yesterday but the most challenging
question of all came last who is your
favorite politician he said Pericles
oh you man of the people you couldn't
resist showing off your lovely classical
education at Eton an Oxford what will it
be next time what's your favorite color
when will you bring world peace do you
have any personal morality at all oh I
think that last one sorry was a real
question I couldn't help myself
Dorothy you you've railed against white
posh boys in the newsroom all your
working life do you think that Boris
sort of fits in with that mold and
that's why you don't particularly like
the Prime Minister
[Music]
I don't say whether I like him or I
dislike him actually last night I also
said that many people say that we should
be against men who are Pale Male and
stale and I was completely opposed to
that view because I think that although
older white men middle class may be
over-represented they are still an
absolutely vital voice to hear but there
is a problem which is that well-off men
who went to private schools and Oxford
and Cambridge still dominate in our
industry you're not like that K I'm not
like that and a key point I made was
that when you change who is making TV
you change what is on TV so I think that
both our politicians and television and
newspaper journalists do and have come
from a very narrow group and we've got
to widen that out I think it's clear
that a lot of journalists and
politicians did not foresee brixey and I
think that is probably because they were
cut off from the sort of areas that you
and I come from k where we probably had
more idea that the rest of the British
population wasn't thinking like that
metropolitan elite he wants to cut us
out
I'm guessing other politicians will want
to do the same sort of things by
embracing Facebook lives and basically
circumventing broadcasters should
broadcasters like us like you like the
other major broadcasters acknowledge
that the delivery of news is changing or
should we just ignore him on Facebook
that doesn't really make him Putin s
does it just because he's embracing
another form of social media
I think it's great that he's embracing
another form of social media and Channel
4 News and I know at sky digital news is
incredibly important to us and it's a
fantastic way of reaching young people
but it's not instead of us so when I
last checked last night 192 thousand
people had watched his facebook Q&A but
the last BBC debate was watched by 5
million people so the first thing that
you've got is far you're reaching far
more people 75 percent of people in this
country depend on television news as
their main source of news so that's one
thing but the other thing is that under
regulation we have to be Julie impartial
fair and accurate and the problem with
Boris Johnson doing something on
Facebook live is that's completely
unregulated also of course they choose
who will take which questions they will
take and there are no follow-ups to
those questions now I know that if you
were interviewing Boris Johnson and you
were interviewing him at length you're
an informed journalist you'd have been
up all night the night before really
prepping to make sure you knew all the
facts and then you could really
scrutinize what Boris Johnson had said
yes give him a proper time to explain it
I'm against interrupting politicians too
much but he has to explain it you
scrutinize it he justifies it and then
the public can make up their minds for
themselves what they think if you just
throw out an old question to a
politician and he gets to give whatever
answer he wants without anybody saying
hang on a minute is that true I don't
think that that's really help
the public I'm not saying he shouldn't
do it I'm saying it is in no way a
substitute for proper journalism of the
child may I say you are famous for well
some broadcasters certainly had their
nose part of joints because he wouldn't
take part in the debates quite recently
me amongst them how do we persuade
politicians election just around the
corner how do we persuade them to come
to the table this time well one of the
things that I did last night was give
them the facts that 75% of people in
this country used television news as
their main form of news that is
extraordinary reach and also 71 percent
of the population trusts television news
whereas and this was a proper Reuters
Institute survey only 22% of the
population trusts internet news and 10%
of the population trusts news on social
so if politicians want the message they
give to be trusted there is in fact no
better place for them to do that than on
TV where they get the reach and there is
the the basic trust of the viewers and I
think also we have to embarrass them and
last night I pointed out that Margaret
Thatcher did this Margaret Thatcher
regularly put herself up for 30-minute
interviews 45-minute interviews they
were very tough interviews I never heard
anybody say Margaret Thatcher refused to
be interviewed but we have two political
leaders now who are simply not being
interviewed and I think partly I have to
just say that isn't right the fact that
we have a prime minister who has not
given a single major press conference or
a single significant into
you since he became our prime minister
that is worrying and again I look across
the ocean and what do I see I see a
president whose eye has abandoned the
famous White House briefings and instead
says that if you as a journalist want to
interview him you have to throw
questions at him as he's out and about
and I don't know if your viewers will
have noticed this but that's what's been
happening since Boris Johnson became our
prime minister he hasn't done major
sit-down interviews but instead he's
doing little bits of through me some
questions while he's out and about and
because I must be equal about this
Jeremy Corbyn similarly does not hold
himself to account does not do regular
long interviews of the type that leaders
in the past did and indeed with him
sometimes were only allowed one question
and in the case of channel four when we
only got one question one day he
actually didn't answer the one question
we got so how can we know what the
policies of these politicians really are
and whether they cut the mustard if if
we don't get to see them being properly
questions and I'm not speaking on behalf
of us as journalists but it's for the
voters and for our democracy we need to
pressurize them to sit down and talk to
us okay I guess
number 10 would say that he's sitting
down with all the major broadcasters at
the g7 this weekend if they were here to
answer that